tutti ragazzi e prevede questo video
sono fa dj ed oggi siamo su family wines
su prey nella mia vita ho sempre pensato
che avrei potuto giocare qualsiasi
sembrò stai calmo e la mia vita ho
sempre pensato di poter giocare a
qualsiasi cosa hai presente che a natale
siamo tutti più buoni
se non fosse natale ti avrei già
insultato la famiglia cominciamo ragazzi
ancora non ho giocato e già paiono cose
che è bellissimo per carità mi piace un
sacco nostro gioco di steam che dao lee
j gere
ecco quando entra in una casa
abbandonata e c'è una bambina che
somiglia vagamente a miley cyrus non è
mai un buon segno ma comparsa una
bambina quindi fotte sega anche se si
aprono solo non è proprio un buon segno
per tale è un giorno e io io sono fuori
j
avrei bisogno di sapere chi apre le
porte premesso salve
che bello che sta cosa più horror che
abbiamo visto in tutta la mia vita
quando c'è lo schermo blu di windows mi
sono ristabilito la finiamo di aprire
porte a caso non lo chiedo è perché non
è proprio normale permesso a una lettera
al girone a si apre tutto nell'armadio
bello io non ho mai buio dei dolci vini
tace narnia a narnia penso che vogliono
uccidermi c'è scritto su questo foglio
non so di chi a chi si riferisca
e l'ora del tè no perché a mezzanotte in
genere si dorme non vorrei darti sa che
questo è bello non una pizza che posso
passar vita mia veder le porte che si
aprono e si chiudono
cos'è sta roba si stenta e la non è
bello ho rotto qualche 18 tutto possa
continuare ma laddove dato e mi carica
fammi capire cioè non ho salvato io non
so dove sta
carica ok ma vado avanti nel senso non
mi guardo indietro se c'è un portatile
pizza di liberi 3 che ha ordinato la
pizza ragazzi che qualcuno qualcuno ha
ordinato la pizza non so chi ebbe bene
bene grazie della pizza possa accendere
la luce chi è che ha ordinato una pizza
non guardarla ma non non guardare chi in
miley cyrus
ok non so che devo guardare chi non devo
guardare ma [ __ ]
[Musica]
morisse il cugino di terzo grado di
atroci sofferenze alle emorroidi cioè
motivo se non un ascolto musica classica
però vabbè ce l'ha fatta a fare un gioco
che sia un gioco normale per cortesia
[Musica]
chiudi chiudi chiudi via via via foto e
semmai di aba possa entrare qui cosa si
possa entrare grazie dove stiamo andando
lega salve so chi sia ma non la devo
guardare non la guardo grazie è bello
bello velo via via via via via via
veloce veloce lassù affetto porca
[ __ ]
vai vai vai vai vai vai vai meglio e sto
andando non lo so apri porta a caso ha
prima chiudi chiudi chiudi chiuri kg
porca eva melo parlare un panino 6
vogliono cioè almeno avevo alcuni amici
in cantina bene ragazzi ragazzi
ok ok no dov'è il mouse spiegatemi
perché non è pozzi che cos'è starò che
gioco è mano e verificando ma è una roba
pazzesca perché non te l'aspetti
e orribile che non capisci quando devi
fare incontro spunta michele però 6 la
mamma [ __ ] dirlo prima e ragazzi mi
fate capire dove devo andare
non me ne frega un cazzo cavi ha via via
di no no no no no no è tutto c'è tutto
voglio tutto voi è tutto buio buio tutto
fottutamente buio no no no no no no non
per favore per l'amor di dio cosa ho
colpito le grazie ma l'importante ma c'è
un buco sono certo dio
[ __ ] [ __ ] ai cosa devo fare di
melo c'è un buco c'è un buco devo andare
[Musica]
nei book ma c'è un modo per allontanare
la pizza la pizza la cosa che ho capito
è che non devo entrare nelle forze che
si affronta sole quindi a di conoscerlo
passato porca [ __ ] la borsa scaricati
scaricati scaricati prima che entri
vade retro ti spacco il computer oddio
oddio non ho mai preso non l'ha presa
non va preso non m'ha preso non aveva
preferisco buttarmi nella cantina di
prima grande ma non negli ordinato la
pizza avevo visto quella che gattonava
dentro a cantina non c'è un modo per
superare in modo tale che non arrivi la
bimba nella cantina
vade retro a delebio non ha preso ha
preso ma preso la freccia per un attimo
ho creduto di poter devo resistere
proprio finché non arriva la macchina
c'è un e vena del fremiti il problema è
che non riuscirò a fare manco un ora o
se ce l'ho fatta ho superato i loro
ragazzi dopo un'ora vera come passare da
un ora e ho superato la fantastico e so
che superata l'ora in teoria dovrebbe
essere ancora più difficile se è ancora
peggio se babbo natale che vi chiedo di
babbo natale non è stata bella ed è
qualcos'altro faccio cadere le forbici
sums buon natale ragazzi perché non è
una non valida ma non pensavo che
potesse usare il teletrasporto tipo goku
quindi è una è una sorta di clown sto
tizio quindi adesso faccio la torcia
così posso vedere dentro ripostiglio
fantastico da dove sul tasto tizio
adesso che la torcia la missione è una
sola praticamente devo andare a vedere
nel ripostiglio c'e devo vedere che cosa
c'è lì sotto non temere yuri da [ __ ]
tanto scende uguale nero zia vero zia
attaccherà da ragazzino che episodio
loro interrotto a metà perché in teoria
continua ancora per un bel po
scopro anche un sacco di altre cose con
quello che per questo episodio perché
sono mica viene lungo un chilometro
spero che vi sia piaciuto ragazzi perché
è un'alternativa tipo fa in extremis ma
cazzuta
serio comunque ragazzi spero che video
vi sia piaciuto e cosa vide piaciuto
momento è un mi piace anche a pagina di
facebook che come noi video totale
sfizio
spero che state passando tutti quanti
nelle buone feste e io prima di questo
video si adesso non tanto ma comunque
sia ci rivediamo in un prossimo video
della ragazza